the man arrested in connection with the
death of a missing woman will be in
court for the first time tomorrow
meantime the family gathered on a zoom
call tonight to consider their i should
say to continue their plea for justice
in finding the second suspect in leslie
palacio's death
authorities are looking for this man
25-year-old eric rangel
ibarra investigators say eric killed
palacio then left the country with his
father
46-year-old jose rangel seen here taken
into custody last week
near the u.s mexico border the family
and their attorneys spoke of how they
want to search in california nevada and
in texas
and want eric to know if he hears this
he needs to turn himself
in it's very disappointing for the
family to see
that somebody that they have trusted and
have known for so many years
um could do something like this to their
sister to their daughter
um they just want some answers
they they're just they can't wait to see
eric in custody so anyone with
information on eric's whereabouts are
urged to call crime stoppers that local
number is
55
702-385-5555